so the tell by talk is oral history at
the crossroads sharing authority in
practice in project-based research and I
sort of begin with Michael Trish's
comment we need projects that will
involve people and exploring what it
means to remember and what to do with
memories to make them active and alive
as opposed to mere objects of
collections and I've often found Michael
frisch's work to be to be very inspiring
I think it's fair and i found formal
with the presentation like i really
enjoyed the informal part earlier more
Hawaiian probably but I wasn't sure what
to expect so I went I went formal with
the presentation I'm going to see our
number of photographs I don't like using
PowerPoint with a lot of words on them
you can see photographs from from our
Montreal like stories project and I find
still photography is a great way to sort
of capture and represent collaboration
in process you know there's still images
but but there's nothing still nothing
still about them so I think it's fair to
say that the loan interviewer has long
dominated the imagination of oral
historians so much so in fact that world
history practice has often been equated
with the interviewer interviewee
relationship exclusively most of the
fields training guides and mythological
articles assume that the interviewer is
also the primary researcher the
authority is shared it is generally
understood within the confines of the
interview and its transcription error
has therefore been remarked these little
reflection on oral history methodology
and ethics in project-based research nor
have we seriously considered how world
history practice is being transformed by
new media and the arts we're living in a
quite remarkable moment by the way
recent calls to share Authority after
the interview have complicated matters
further opening up new spaces of
community university conversation
increasingly the recorded interview is
but one step which is a lot our
continuum of collaboration in
collaborative projects the
between the researcher and the research
is sometimes blurred and what is on and
off the record is somewhat ambiguous
this change in context demands I mean
widened our conception of world history
practice and consider the ethical
challenges and responsibilities in
community University collaboration my
talk this evening I proposed to explore
these issues within the specific context
of the Montreal life stories project a
major closet of research project
investigating the life stories of
Montreal errs displaced by war genocide
and other human rights violations
through the evidence of life history
interviewing and collective storytelling
we asked how large scale violence is
experienced and remembered what does it
mean to be a survivor of mass violence
and living in North America how to
individuals and communities construct
and transmit their stories for their
children and grandchildren when where
and why our particular stories about
mass while is told and by whom we also
asked how these life stories are like
histories can be represented and
communicated to wire public's oral
history has a pivotal role to play in
educating us at our communities both the
social preconditions experiences and
long-term repercussions of crimes
against humanity through multi-session
life history interviewing we wanted to
understand mass violence in the context
of logs lived and remembered so
situating it in the before and the after
as a result the person and here we have
Sarah gypsy song from the occasion
community rather than the event in this
case the violence perpetrated by the
duvalier dictatorship in haiti how the
person rather than event framed the
interview we wanted to know what
happened but also to understand better
how bass violin siz remembered and
what's impact has been over the longer a
as a ripple out
through individual lives families and
communities the Montreal life stories
project was funded by the community
university research alliance or Kira for
short program of shirt which is the
major funder of academic research in
Canada accurate program is a special one
that is premise on the idea that
communities can be partners in research
and not simply objects of study learning
with communities such as the Rwandan
community pictured here represents a
fundamentally different way of doing
research and what is normally practiced
in our universities who is actually
within the research conversation matters
as it shapes what we do how we envision
our projects the questions we ask the
technologies we adopt or design and why
we do what we do the project began in
2006 the 40 team members evenly divided
between university-based researchers
from a broad range of disciplines and
community co applicants from seventeen
partner organizations these were mainly
volunteer groups in the cities Rwandan
Cambodian Haitian and Jewish communities
will also include the National Film
Board the Canadian Council for Refugees
which is a major advocacy group on
refugee rights the virtual Holocaust
Memorial Center a professional theatre
covering the school boards and many
others in the years that followed the
project grew to more than 300 people as
community members artists educators
interns and students streamed into the
project many team members with
themselves survivors of ass violence
others were the children or
grandchildren of those displaced there
was even a bit of a family chain
migration into the projects as one
member that another and another joined
in the presence of large numbers of
young people to change the conversation
raising questions about
intergenerational transmission identity
for example as there was and is a great
deal of silence within
families and communities the project was
built on the idea of a shared Authority
a phrase we all know was coined by
Michael frisch in 1990 to describe the
co-creation of the interview the
dialogic nature of the interview the
researchers questions and the narrator's
responses produces a unique source not
every interview is the same however and
true partnership must constantly be
worked out a good interview route
psychologist Henry Greenspan is a
process in which two people work hard to
understand the views and experience of
one person the interviewee a good
collaborative project works in much the
same way community University
collaboration need not begin and end
with recorded interview to signal our
commitment to sharing authority degree
to community university Perry in the
composition of the project's
Coordinating Committee hiring committees
and project live committees such as
ethics prof couldn't simply hire their
own that is usually the case in the
university of research our approach
therefore differ from other projects and
that we emphasize an integrationist
model of blended community university
teams of researchers rather than the
partnership model of the four world sort
of memorandum of understanding which
which you often see in canada are coming
together was of course not without its
challenges in the early days we struggle
to find common ground some project
researchers and community partners were
primarily interested in understanding
mass violence over there and ensuring
that never was never forgotten others
were more interested in the refugee
experience in Montreal our decision to
forefront of the transnational life
story resolved this tension it also had
the value of putting people first
exploring what Matusz file is met those
most
directly affected too often Warren
genocide or under space in the abstract
or the area community university
research allows us to push beyond the
ways in which recorded interviews are
often used in human rights research and
advocacy and here I'm thinking of the
critique of made by Sidney Smith and key
shaker as a highly effective
illustrative device strategically placed
for maximum impact or is aggregate data
in a water accumulation of eyewitness
evidence in each instance survivors
accounts are not permitted to live in
green at the outset we needed to
determine how to organize ourselves we
were made in getting bigger should
working groups being organized around
specific cultural communities if so how
will the others under undertake
intercultural or comparative research
dibby risk creating cultural silos
recruits to organize transversely around
key themes if so would this book
university researchers into the driver's
seat you can see the subtle push and
pull in the end seven groups formed for
organized around specific jaspera
Haitian Rwandan Cambodian and Jewish
this is the Cambodian working group and
three around transversal themes refugee
youth education and performance the
project structure enabled team members
to function to multiple languages as
English French Khmer and Kinyarwanda
were all regularly spoken in the
day-to-day in the in approach X
operations so the Cambodian work working
group worked in French and Khmer the
Rwanda working group worked in French
and Kinyarwanda the performance working
group report mainland English and so on
interviews were also conducted in creole
Spanish nur and arabic so the
interviewed in people's home home
languages project research can be quite
particle leading to a division of labor
between field work and interpretation
this problem is mitigated an
interpretive power is widely shared with
community members free or co-authoring
many of the projects outcomes the
projects working group structure also
helps as decision-making power was
decentralized to large degree another
potential problem facing large projects
is fragmentation as large projects
devolved into a number of small ones I
think evolved in part projects I've been
hard projects like that how might we
ensure a project wide research horizon
while still working in smaller groups
big challenge our projects coordinating
committee composed of four faculty
members and for community members were
responsible for overall direction the
projo also organized an annual assembly
and six international conferences what
found the project together most was
everyday interaction as our entire team
that's based in Montreal and this is a
conscious decision that we made at the
beginning that everyone had to be within
within the Montreal area our shared
methodology also bound us together as
everyone was required to complete a
six-hour or workshop course as well as
working group specific trainings even I
had to go through that a shared online
space or base camp cloud computing also
helped us as all of our documents
transcriptions chronologies and email
were accessible to team members with
base camp you've been organizing the way
that you work in your own potty don't
see anything else which makes it very
sort of top-down right the coordination
see everything if anybody also just sort
of see their small part of the world we
made the decision that everybody would
see everything except for personnel
issues if you kept separate
university research ethics in Canada
like elsewhere I think it's probably the
same here is premise on the idea that we
can regulate the interaction between two
distinct groups of people who inhabit
different places researchers in one
place and the research over there
accordingly the interaction between the
two can be regulated and pleased in a
debt dusty as the conceit of university
of research ethics university ethics
also assumes that the faculty member is
in control the research process that
they own the process at its products
true collaboration destabilize these
assumptions and all lies learn from the
outset we decide that it was important
that everyone involved the project
faculty students community partners
staff tech support everyone participate
in the interviewing so it'd be a
collective experience so here we see
Gracia Julia master students in
communications near being within the
refugee youth context we wanted to feel
it in our chest that shared experience
now in the process I've come to realize
there's no perfect location for the
interviewer team members interviewed
parents grandparents other members their
own cultural communities made a lot of
like the Cambodian reblogged young
Cambodian young people interviewing
older Cambodians we had community people
interviewing University people we had
University people interviewing community
people and what was really interesting
was that those are many different points
writing a whole constellation to look up
in the sky and all the stars right and
you connect the dots each one each
connection is a different conversation
and I think that was really that
diversity to me was one of the core
strengths of our project in total we
conducted 500 multi-session interviews
once decisions we made was to do
multiple sessions instead of just rain
stand-alone session ranging from 2 to 20
hours the average being around four or
five hours many of these interviews are
in our searchable stories matter
database which you see here so all the
public interviews are now searchable
within our database the longest
interviews with those conducted by the
convertible group which sometimes lasted
20 hours with a single interview session
when six or seven hours over two meals
which I've never experienced so much
I've ever went to experience right for
some reason within the Cambodian working
group that happened fairly frequently
generally the working groups began by
interviewing elders of other projects
and we were off air being young people
even children it's not unusual for team
members to be both interviewer and
interviewee as many more survivors or
sons with others of survivors project
interviewers and videographers were
required to post their interview
reflections on basecamp within 48 hours
of each interview session while it's
still fresh accordingly we now have
almost 1000 written reflections from all
corners of the project now this is a
remarkable sight of reciprocal research
I'd like to quote something from Shawn
field a grace of African story when you
wrote to sustain empathic listening to
stories of extreme trauma sense of
introspection of one's feelings during
after the interview is essential and I
certainly agree with that that we often
we really sought ways to bind to build
in reflexivity try and enter into our
process now let me proud this
observation in the specific example at
least five team members interviewed
their fathers to each from the Cambodian
the Rwandan groups and one from the
Sephardic research cluster how each
person chose to write about the
experience interviewing their father in
their blogs very dramatically Sandra
casada who you see here on the right
interview your father Oscar
and used her reflection to defend her
decision to interview her father there
have been some debate within the
projects were wandering group but
whether the children of survivors should
be allowed to view their parents or not
whether this is a good thing or not
really too close or not and so in her
reflection she used it as a chance to
sort of argue back right to that other
argument she thought that the projects
memory were should operate not only
within in between communities but also
within families themselves and she went
on to interview her four sisters who
actually a little bit later we're going
to hear additional story from her
younger sister Stephanie other children
of survivors approached the exercise in
completely different ways in her blog
read one who's ranked here this is our
book launch for remembering mass
violence and so she was one of the
editors and she was the leader of the
Cambodian working group in her blog
doesn't even mention that's her father
you did you think she's here doing a
stranger right she distanced herself
entirely and not just within the blog
within the interview itself when we
listen to him by contrast Paula Tom this
is Paul Tom his sister Matt betadine who
became involved through the performance
group and this is his father and mother
this is a art installation coming out of
the project Paul Tom use the entire blog
to reflect on his relationship to his
father and his father's story in this
incidence it was his father who spoke in
the third person throughout the
interview so his father that was making
all assistance
in the interview Paula found that this
was strange i quote set a pas de mon
pere keep are they made the toughest
serves up my father who spoke a
professor there's a great deal of
silence and Paul's family about the
Khmer Rouge and Paul had many questions
for his father we decide knocked energy
was father directly and serve as
videographer so several left the
children shows that the geographers spot
has sort of a safe safe space he went on
to write in this blog well I wanted at
this stage of my relationship with my
father to position myself as an observer
behind the camera I did not want to
force things I wanted to love all to
listen now later Paul produced an
award-winning short anime film about
these these family silences I wanted to
to play you now it's four minutes long
it's in French listen to the voice
watches Nana make it short and it won
the prize and the muscle under the
pseudonym insulting to clean children to
gentleman's is
well
we prefer me to the only strong to sit
down or Pesci in the current event
the semester hawlucha is to be able to
toronado an emotional this issue for my
gosh
it's really insist on pjs horse when you
need me there you know you're a secure
isuzu a crucible pirate name or obese
person doesn't finger won't work
Recology in a partner Harvey Nichols p
of xi an almost Sufi talking design we
were so eager to hear
ok some other day you spoke about this
and knowledge were your honor what if a
sitting over here to Shakira sauce over
me
you should be hated I don't miss you
okay disoriented
perfectly healed
miss you so
so from the start make great that
collection was not enough North American
archives are filled to the rafters
hundreds of thousands of nearly
recordings have never been listening to
this is the day that they were recorded
we therefore sought to integrate these
stories into our installations audio
walks radio programming we had a weekly
library of programming over a year and
then we still have a radio production
shop within our in our Center that's
producing radio stories every every week
essentially documentary film five or six
and come out of this project so far
pedagogical cherries of all kinds there
was an immersive bus tour which
integrate stories of Palestinians and
others intergenerational conversations
like this one where where we had a whole
day where we're about 70 or 80 people
from the Cambodian community came
together just sort of speak across
generation and watch interview clips to
sort of you know as a way to sort of
generate schedule 500 subway cars were
equipped with QR codes digital stories
over over over a month there was a
year-long museum exhibition I already
mentioned the searchable database and
theatrical performances ranging from
gestural theater are you focusing on the
hands 2 2 playback verbatim theatre
sound theatre Youth Theatre this is a
comp
this is a congolese project and a
full-scale professional theater play
around the Armenian Armenian Genocide
there's also scholarly publications like
remembering mass violence in each
instance we sought to use oral history
interviews and life stories is catalyst
for personal reflection public dialogue
and education so in digital storytelling
for example instead of extracting those
parts the current interviews that speak
to us as researchers we ask interviewees
themselves what story they would like to
share with the world so you've been
interviewed for five hours seven hours
eight hours 20 hours what have you so
you've got five minutes what story you
want to share with the world we asked
them that and then we also invited them
to actually co-produce the digital
stories that went online with the
National Film Board which is government
institution so give it credibility and
so on you can view those those those
digital stories on our website so I
wanted to play a additional story from
from Stephanie gusano and this comes out
of the refugees were against emotion
when tested in one of his speeches and
the tootsies should put their memories
and things about this herself Mack it
and put it in little burst midnight look
forward and focus in the future as his
answer and their way to connect the pass
to the credit without you passed toy and
doesn't matter if England knows my
family is trying to protect me finger
story especially my sister challenge who
my protector to the same without her
from kidney the capital of western
province of wonder but my life stories
so different from my sisters to begin
with but 50 meters apart then Phillips
are generally have in common event in
both Cape Charles have asked myself if
you look at a journal page from they
were about 50 would you know that we
came from the same family that will be
sisters if I've been there at the same
time is it sister hi Reuben life have
been different sister silences secrets
I'll request to discover my family story
unless this time I went to rail at home
and occasional drills could you look
analysis sisters my pleasure the same
parents battle the German who has
adventure and once more protective
looking for stability a home run in
worship right I have grown up in my
place I was with the recent you will
show you I do so touch select particular
place as where I have unlimited that's
my ground my god is forever grounded
Alton to edit so every hand never
highlighted stolen base she's moved from
my finals to convert windy young-hee
filter moved up to measure ferns and
finally carrier which is palacios below
notice there's not been contrition color
and we were to ever that family could
you work in the facility i was born in
nineteen ninety in every window full of
look and reconciliation it was an
elephant repairs as well they I decided
to have third child I mentioned upon my
other sisters i was born in the best and
most my parents eventually decided to go
their separate ways and forget that past
winter Jones and too we're doing
negative attitude my father wanted to
make up for last time my man deliver
lamps to taking care of me and so I
would know so many mother and the rest
of my family spread all over the world
so much my sister has variable beginning
of my family story and my parents were
first coming together she was brilliant
ooh a week community hihi defender of
those colors and and then everything
tragically ended with a joke site and
last extended family and last I found me
at the same time it for me to lay about
the identity nice to us could you
recommend us accessories I am originally
from under burn speak the language and
another Luther and was never really able
to visit from we're living week sometime
because we don't have any
goes left and so adding Dilip in burley
which is a memorial to 90 celibate I
feel if you get I am happy when I speak
the language when the ether food listen
to music in recognized in helping people
so radiant living and has trouble
defending your identity quite the
country hers she remembers being told
that she had no entity that I family was
faithless don't tell any of them went my
dad said to her and she says to me today
telling the kid to keep something from
someone even if asurion candy and told
them I had to touch it if you only learn
hi like us my sister tells me and I
learned to find out my past experiences
the family are and it was time for me to
find a definition for my family's I have
so many questions for so long however we
will go home when you're moving all the
time would require were set for refugee
a night to forget our bearings we've
ever show with your children could
really make a difference some questions
were left unanswered and so I asked
myself how I should I wanna know how
much shadow how much let's shoot around
me too I like to move past the secrets
understand the ins working and all of
the ups and downs financially socially
and emotionally my sister knows the
secrets and I'm trying to recover them
jeans may lead
my right and I will make just as much as
she wants you to
so life digital storytelling there's a
great deal of synergy between oral
history and Performing Arts already
mentioned the wide variety of theatrical
forms used by team members in staging
world history on each of these Theatre
Projects raised unique questions and
challenges like to briefly our news do
two of these these projects I mentioned
one earlier to the students so I listen
to it again incendie bhagwati is
gestural theatre meditations he combines
traditional text with contemporary
fragments from those marked by mass
violence the fragments are just rolled a
composer of chamber and orchestral music
megawati directed each actor study the
gestural repertoire of a single
interviewee making them thorough and yes
they were told to watch the interviews
with the audio turned off as a result
the actors knew very little about the
person whose gestures they were
mimicking the act of suppression of
voice raises questions of course but I
think productive ones in reading body
language in isolation to artists end up
projecting their own feelings and
assumptions on to others whose story is
it and again all historians regularly
suppress the body without a second
thought are we and better as part of
this process my body discovered that
people's bodies remember when someone
was remembering 1930s Poland for example
their body language changed to what it
would have been in that cultural
historic context he was able to show
that prove that through through deep
analysis of the video recordings that we
conducted by contrast voices and bodies
are put back into conversation in the
work of the living histories ensemble a
playback theatre group embedded in the
project playback theatre invites
audience members to share their stories
in a collective storytelling space once
told the actors represent the story back
through improvised sound
movements and scenes the original
storyteller then gets the opportunity to
respond I have to admit I have mixed I
had mixed feelings at first as normal
the story always drawn a line between
oral history and therapy but here was
the art form embedded in an oral history
project that comes out of drama therapy
is an intensely personal way of
eliciting memories too personal for some
people it did not take long however
before I was persuaded by what I saw as
a living histories ensemble worked with
each community in turn fur stations in
the hall and Holocaust survivors their
children then the rwandan community and
in the Cambodian community the impact of
these community-based playback sessions
were profound and the stories shared
often not the same ones told within the
interview space so different kinds of
storytelling spaces leads to different
kinds of stories being shared and I
thought there's also a big difference
between his community-based playback
storytelling sessions and ones that were
open to the public or where I just have
a sense of war being the voyeur onto
someone else's story or someone else's
pain whereas within the community ones I
thought that was sort of litigators to a
large degree clearly then the mantra
life stories project has many different
kinds of spaces where stories are being
told they're intensely where the ethical
issues raised in every meeting workshop
performance screening and even email is
part of our ongoing conversation in
subject to reflection and publication in
collaboration self-reflexivity and
ethnography become virtually
indistinguishable in partnership what
constitutes their research activity of
the project and is therefore subject to
university ethics and what does not
becomes working as a result your costs
like basis
ethical questions practically speaking
what you informed consent run it
withdrawal and the mitigation of harm
mean in these other project spaces as I
mentioned early the earlier the
interview is the most hyper regulated
space around it's only one space moment
so how do we deal with other this is
wider view collaboration and shared
authorship was crucial in my experience
in avoiding but some people in
Aboriginal studies call the form
disciplinary gays Sidney Smith and case
Schaefer have raised the troubling
questions about the use of life story
material by human rights organizations
where little bits of first-person
testimony are deployed as an
authenticating device for non-resident
human rights workers and researchers
populace lease listening autobiography
rights Julie salver some really great
theater theorists I've recommender
hardly thoughtlessly soliciting
autobiography neighbor reproduce a form
of cultural colonialism that is at the
very least we're history can just as she
adds the orchestra or at least inspired
by presenting pain as unexamined
spectacle and sharing survivor stories
to be risked arata sizing injury is
sharing always the right thing to do if
not under what circumstances can life
stories be shared volume and with whom
these are key questions and who gets to
decide is crucial on this note I'd like
to end this presentation with an example
taken from the Rwandan working group
next month will be 20 years since 1990
or genocide its earliest days the life
stories project has benefited from the
significant sustained involvement of
montreal's Rwandan community the largest
and Canada the nineteen group members
all the three four ever wanted origins
including the scholar so that the
cultural divide that you often seen
between university-based researchers in
the communities that are being studied
was not there within networking group
one of the great strengths of our
working groups structure is that it
provides space a community directed
research within the larger community
university framework the Rondon group
was less responsible for the interview
coordination within its own community
the memory work of the Rwandan group
culminated in a day of reflection which
brought together about 120 people for
seven hours the day's events were
reduced by kelis cabeza was the leader
of the group who reminded everyone that
community members knew their own history
is our history he said our little
histories within the big history of our
country colleague said spoke of the
pressing need to transmit this history
to young people in the community over
the course of the day there was an
audience including many of the inner
duties themselves wats three 20-minute
digital stories drawn from interviews
they compose themselves sort of
tapestries each one's attack escape a
roundtable panel then spoke after each
screening followed by question as your
periods in the first two instances the
commentators were all interviewees the
spoke of their firsthand experiences in
the third the panel consisted of young
people who spoke of exile survival and
integration in Quebec you may have heard
is a big debate now and go back around
the cultural sharda really want to ban
all religious clothing or symbols
to public servants so see so the French
wall are trying to apply it apply and
Quebec the discussion was honest we're
doing differences of opinion about the
role of the Catholic Church in the
genocide everyone seemed to ask why the
violence why us throughout the day
participants were invited to fill out
square memory cards like this one and
pin them on the front wall under
specific years they had 1945 all the way
to 2012 this Linda Thomas this Highline
activity results in an entire wall
covered in brightly colored memory cards
at the end of each session people slowly
wrote down the selected memory or two
and walked to the front to place it with
all the others the community's history
that took shape from all of these
individual memories the memory workshop
was organized from my and for Montreal's
Rwandan community this to me represents
the full climate of potential a
community university research normally
the historical timeline is the preserve
of the historian or journalist who
decides what was and was not significant
typically it tells us only of the big
history robards ibis perspective here by
contrast we see a timeline created
collaboratively from the little
histories drawn from individual memory
recorded interviews that served as a
catalyst for dialogue within the
community bridging those exile before
1994 and those who experienced the
genocide directly who are in Rwanda 19
or that was a big chasm within within
the community it also connected young
people born after the genocide who live
in its shadow and a few cases it also
brought to see in food to into
conversation one of the academics in the
working group was a Hutu psychologist
which was a big important moment with
him within the community in all these
cases community members connected their
little histories to the big history of
colonialism decolonization the Cold War
and of course the world's complicity in
the 1994 genocide it was not a timeline
drained of its emotional content history
is intensely personal also I think
belongs to all of us so that's open up
that's the formal the project was from
2005 2012 but it's still continuing in
the sense of publication so we had a
launch of the first edited collection in
January as a monograph being launched
next month is the second edit question
called beyond testimony trauma oral
history in the aftermath of mass
violence coming out in February and
another book is in the works the
different working groups have have like
the Rwandan group and the Cambodian
Gurkha create documentation center so
one of the things that he had the
project was we didn't want at all the
products just residing within the
university's everything was replicated
so all the public interviews all you
know all those laws everything are are
in the mitral holocaust memorial set
rwandan documentation side of the
Cambodian documentation center there's a
little asian organization right it's
that way they they're building capacity
within their own their own communities
that was a big part of our project was
that we wanted to build capacity within
the communities themselves and so the
young people were often the interview
coordinators and so on you know they're
still very much you know at the
forefront of things when the project yes
one was asked me like it's a very
intense kind of project right likes a
lot of things happening as a lot of
people began with 40 ed but over 300 we
decided that we didn't want to
immediately apply for another grant in
the sense that we needed to sort of
coffee Oh like you needed to sort of
recover right from 57 years and I
thought there was a good decision
because I think one of the tendencies
might be coming to get into autopilot
becomes institutional in a way right and
this way you know we're wrapping up and
I think what the next project would be
around the archive itself and thinking
about a living archive these five
hundred interviews and and working them
within the in the different communities
and so on that's still going on next
next month we have in April we have all
kinds of activities and of course all
these different people are part of the
Center for oral history and digital
storytelling so they are still very much
present still very active right but the
project has sucks right ended in 2012
officially think one of the challenges
and sharing with already beyond the
interview is getting the Mariners to
want to share the work and the time
investment of making these kinds of
public product so it seems clearly the
fact that you involve the community
groups and narrator should
beginning of the firing process would
get people invested then I'm wondering
what else you were able to do to keep
people involved at that level and
particularly in terms of sharing funding
and distributing cleansing so actually
that the initial phase is the key phase
of any project that's when the
structures get created in expectations
and so on and so we spent a year
imagining that project so from 2005-2006
we met monthly and they grew organically
right and and and made a decision that
we're not going to fund individuals
we're going to only fund the constituent
parts so you had to have eat he has
seven working groups right in order to
be a working group you had to have with
the University and community at the
table so we had we had three excellent
Latin American researchers but they had
no connection to the community groups in
the Montreal so they couldn't form a
Latin American working group but they
were involved in the refugee youth group
right and so that's you know so so one
of the issues that we faced the
beginning was when the dangers of our
project is that we're locating the
violence everywhere else but here right
so it becomes like another sort of
underground railway kind of story right
and so we did a lot of events with an
Aboriginal injury report / pool with
Aboriginal survivor French are
essentially bullying or we would have
joy screening so we see to our digital
stories plus their digital stories right
now I think you know you know there was
I think certainly pressure within the
project politically to expand all right
so expanded within within the groups
like the Haitian group began with a very
much focused on work out look at
Duvalier Europe you know 1960s refugees
of course young people are coming in and
saying well I'm a refugee from era Steve
what is love when rights violations
since then right and and so they they
force an open right and also they have
to interviewed you know beyond that that
first generation of
patient exiles in Montreal which is a
hugely important group and then the
three sort of non sort of poultry
specific working groups they did a lot
of heavy liftings or beyond sort of the
four institutionalized partnerships I
guess you can say so that's where we had
like air dudes like you know work being
done in the Palestinian community which
isin screencap Palestinian work going on
in the same project as a Holocaust
survivors and Sephardic Jews right I
think that was were able to do that
because it was sort of you know you know
decentralized to some extent whenever
there was things up so he was a budget
that was agreed to but I think people
did not spend their budgets the money
went into a central envelope we had an
open competition that we were able to
fund things that were new that we hadn't
expected right as every year not
committee with the community university
committee and so when someone comes up
there's I have a great idea fun me and
here does the University for his new
yarn thinking about losses for right you
won't get funded very less like right
and so that's that flexibility that
institutional flexibility i think served
as well and so we grew and then at each
working group worked as a collective and
so when people apply to join the working
group of decide whether yes or no you
can join or not and so some working
groups were like no we did want to grow
too much renovation group said you know
tens it up right I've no more right you
know the Cambodian it's just crazy right
it was like everyone so it varied from
from group to group that elasticity to
me was really important and so it's not
standardized you know each the dynamic
each group was different which me is not
a problem yep
so so cross so there were 10 crops you
gotta course release right as part of a
university funding Canada you get a
course release we put the same amount of
money into community release so as
identical amount of money but it was but
how do you deliver it right it's the
question right because most these people
have day jobs and not working our
partners were not partners were their
hired researchers right yeah they're
working at you know reckon wherever
right and so the their employer so what
we did was you gave honorariums right
nobody can cover like daycare are
killing all the stuff right that was
just matter of course so any community
member that have any kind of
administrative load which man on a
committee or co-leader of our Hoover
automatically got got got we call
community release like automatically it
wasn't like a deciding thing and that
way we thought it had it was fair I'm
the same amount of money in terms of the
project thank you for your presentation
I am very interested in the multimedia
aspect to it strikes me as real you know
real achievement you showed us very
different media princess the film the
short beautiful thing by Paul Tonko that
used a style which was unrealistic and
the digital story was a circular
narrative like many African stories are
and then you had written reflections and
you had an exhibition so and also some
of these expressions work done by
professionals who said in some will not
so the old the question is how do you
keep all this together I am involved in
a project
very different but we share the
multimedia ambition and there is a
serious question of how you keep these
things together and also how you share
them with the question positionality it
exists so when one mechanism that we
have right was we had an artist in
residency program so so every year we
were able fund a couple artists from the
communities themselves right and they
would make a proposal and the committee
again was was a blended committee and
and and they would do all kinds of stuff
right and and and and you know sometimes
they would serve riff off someone else's
like so it's like serving dialogue or
counter dialogue right I just example
for gestural theater next year you know
someone proposed sound theater where is
the exact opposite right and so you have
this you had a synergy way back and
forward with digital storytelling it was
more and with radio it was more
centralized so we had this radio
production shop called radio works and
so we had using interns and volunteers
and team members you know we had a
partnership with two radio stations and
so we you know we produce content right
centrally the way right and and that
practice changed over time beginning it
was very much sort of professional a
sense of producers go out find the
content go deliver right and by the end
we had changed them right and it may
work flower like why why isn't that
collaborative whereas our digital
storytelling was collaborative right why
why is it different right and so to me
you know to me what was really important
in the project was that there were many
authors many different media right
reaching a variety of different public's
right and they aren't almost saying the
same thing like to me it's like a good
interview a good interview you're
knocking on the door saying
coming year and her opening of the door
here sent from this part of my life and
you're sort of exploring like that right
that's what you're doing a project right
it's the same thing it's the exploration
it's a mutual some exploration and and I
think I think that diversity of
authorship takes off some of the
pressure like if it's all centralized
because a lot of pressure in that
outcome to be all things to all people
right you know like yeah so I have a
book coming out next month my names on
it says Steve hi in the front right
should I feel guilty about that I would
if I was the only outcome of the project
you know I x8 what it's not right you
know but because it's actually the last
thing coming out every else has had
their chance to sort of quote there and
do things I just feel like a late comer
really so I don't feel I don't feel I
don't feel that's that's a problem so to
me it's about a shared conversation
right you know it's a conversation that
matters rather than the conclusions that
individuals draw was talking just let me
do an academic work right yes but I
don't baby you said they all say the
same thing the messages the men to do
the same no they don't stay the same
time in the opposite yeah and just no no
and so you know so like so the digital
storytelling so we had a digital
storytelling record Ashley Paul Tom
right so he was a part-time staffer
right he worked 20 hours a week and so
when interviewees where interview we
sent them like you know the DVD with a
feedback forms we got a third gave us
back but they thought the interview but
also be had an invitation do you want to
get involved in the project in some way
and we give a few choices when was g1
your digital story right and then he
would then work with people and and some
people would be sitting there he had
Holocaust survivors sitting there in her
lab day after day work Oh truly
co-producing something I Paul's here and
there there
they're working at other ones are saying
okay I this is why I want to come back
to me with your you know I'll sign off
on it right and so is much more relaxed
right and so each one was different but
there's this is what we had central and
mechanisms right it's not i'm saying is
mechanism you have you have mechanisms
that allow you know allow us to do
things and some things were grew in
importance like playback theatre it
became a central part of the
conversation not year 19 year too but by
year five and six it became really
important people got used to the idea
compensable what we should be to a video
game I feel the same way I curious about
whether i did had any conversations
across the groups well that how did that
happen destruction
what came out of that great question and
then and it's something that that's one
of the big outcomes i think is in some
the rwandan group organized a conference
early on um testimony one in jenison
2008 and invited the cambodian for
dessert participate and it was a
wonderful of ethics a basically
mobilized academic knowledge from the
community but she was like you won't do
that ok right and and they found a
lesson from all around the world brought
in the montreal was a kid it was the
audience right and the cambodian group
was so impressed by that two years later
they had their own conference or
immobilized global a cadet academic
knowledge right brought in and and and
and you have you know 200 cambodian much
dollars they're getting the best
possible scholarship right so they want
right then you had so the Rwandan
organized this linda thomas
intergenerational conversation
Cambodia's did the same thing right they
both have document education stars
because now an exhibition at the
holocaust memorial center where it's the
Hulk where it's the holocaust center
there were london documentation stare in
the Cambodian Documentation Center code
on it right there could be a rotational
stuff all right and so it's led to all
kinds of connection huge amount of
connection right which wasn't explicit
in our in our grant application it just
happened because people were in
conversation has got inspired by each
other right or Paul Tom I like one of
the key moments for him was when he he
he heard a public testimony about
everyone go to and he was so moved by a
number of this moment you know and and
this was pivotal for him to do this film
right and so you have you know again
each each community is at a different
place to like
of course the Jewish community was you
know it's very well organized long
history of doing work as the other
communities were very interested in
being relationship there but his the
other ones which i also found you know
really quite as far and actually even
the launch of the project the cambodian
group organized that any ely this huge
haul of are walking away oh my god
because it's like huge holland was like
tables like tapestry and artifacts and
you know book a book table all the books
they had and they had student projects
may have a they had a stage where it's
like a black skirt man they had pinned
in ball flowers and cambodian dance they
had cambodian food and and every i say
that i think i said that's an
introduction of the every academic
rumor was like oh my god we got
delivered right all that expectation
right talk about pressure right but then
in the Academy so often we don't have
work we were served in a vacuum but we
live we work served in isolation right
and so to me that was really an
important motivator and I think those
also interesting is over time people
started looking across the working
groups right so so right so to me it's
not necessarily turning away from right
if it's it's depending on how your what
your project sort of about it right but
it's a great article and I think you
know it's a you know that is good
another question we asked a lot of
ourselves is like LA where we just worth
it and even if you need to talk about
that to member one didn't glass
an event they're asking well when is
someone ready to share the story does
that mean huge question okay well thank
you very very much